have you ever setup or managed
distributed database and are tired of
the operational headache or are you
considering moving to one for
scalability and high availability
reasons often times you have to choose
between scalability and consistency but
also ease of setup and manageability are
important factors to consider hi I'm
Robert kubis and in this video series we
talk about Google Cloud spanner a fully
managed relational database service so
do you want to know how to provision and
scale a mission-critical database and
seconds without having to worry about
consistency or maintenance windows stay
tuned to find out when you hear about
loud spanner many things feel and sound
like magic a database that is
horizontally scalable while offering
strong consistency across zones
regions or even globally how is this
possible before we look into some of the
details and technologies how cloud
spanner works let us get your own
instance up and running first in the
Google Cloud console search first banner
click on create instance and you'll find
all you need to set up your instance in
one screen you just name the instance
select the configuration and how many
notes you want done that was easy right
but wait what just happened let's take a
moment here and talk about which
configuration to choose and how many
nodes to select in cloud spanner compute
nodes and storage are separated to
enable scaling each independently on top
new nodes and data are replicated across
multiple zones or even Regents for
higher availability when choosing a
configuration you have the option
between a regional instance in a
particular location or a multi region
instance let's still down a bit further
layer in a regional configuration your
instance compute and storage gets
distributed and replicated across three
zones within one region for instance
your rest or use central what making
sure your data stays available and
consistent across hardware maintenance
software patches or even a failure of an
entire cell but what if you need higher
availability guarantees and a better
read performance from different places
in that case you can choose one of our
multi regional configuring
which distributes your incense to up to
four regions across the globe this
allows for an entire region to become an
unavailable while your database still
works is normal from all the other
regions having your data available in
more than one region also enables faster
reads from those regions and the best of
all you don't have to worry about
setting up your own replication or
failure or instances all this is fully
managed for you in one setting
now what about notes for each note you
request for your instance you get
compute resources in also ins and
regions depending on your selected
configuration there is no need for
difficult planning and forecasting and
how many resources to provision upfront
you can just change the number of
instance notes anytime you need more or
fewer you just click on edit instance
change the number of notes and done
really easy and if you like your
keyboard more than your pointing device
you can do all this from the command
line as well or with our client
libraries that are available in many
many languages your instance is now up
and running actually there has been
ready and waiting for us since we click
the blue little create button so let's
go ahead and create a database and
schema it's recommended to both at the
same time schemas in cloud spanner are
just like any other relational database
you have tables and columns that are
strongly typed and if you need to add a
table or index or remove a column in the
future you can just do so without any
downtime incurred cloudspinner run
schema changes in a long-running
transaction but keep in mind depending
on individual statements that you
execute your schema changes they can
range from minutes for adding a column
through hours for backfilling and index
on a large database now that your
database is created you can use our
client libraries to write and read data
cloud spanner also speaks SQL which lets
you reuse and understeer existing skills
of working with traditional relational
databases the next step is to look into
loading some data and how to do this
efficiently unfortunately we are out of
time in this episode and we will keep
that for the next one so if you want to
learn more about lots better best
practices
and inner-workings follow this video
series and check out the links in the
description in the next episode of
things I learned about loud spanner we
will look at how to pick the right
primary keys to enable fast and
efficient writes and reads and remember
you don't need to sacrifice consistency
for scalability
[Music]
you
[Music]